mike you  called off the wedding  that day the morning of the wedding  why why did you do it  the actual night before the wedding um  i got into my own head i went down to  the river  and i was gone for about five or six  hours  and uh which is by our house and i was  just  i got scared i was overthinking things  um  i just felt a lot of pressure um  i was just feeling lost and  i mean you know i was just not ready to  get married that day  [Applause]  that's cold bro i got cold feet i got  scared like i know like i'm not  i'm not trying to justify it anyway i  feel like a piece  that i that that went down that way i do  i feel horrible  natalie it was tough  that was tough  what were you thinking as you were  watching that back  i i feel like i  i just i don't know i feel like i want  to hug this girl and say everything's  gonna be all right  i just i feel like i'm so little there  and i  i'm like no one can help me and it just  so many stuff running through my head